No matter how well-paid or world famous movie
stars and award winning directors may be,
they're still human - which means they make
as many mistakes as anyone.
Usually those mistakes are left on the cutting
room floor, or offered to fans on blooper
reels for a look behind the scenes, and a
laugh.
But sometimes those same outtakes can wind
up in the spotlight instead - the result of
an editor and director who either never noticed,
or decided it was just too good to take out.
But we'll let you be the judge.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Movie Outtakes That
Made It To The Big Screen.
Star Wars
Just about every movie fan has seen the Star
Wars Saga at least once, but there's a good
chance even die hard fans have overlooked
one of the biggest mistakes in the franchises
first movie.
When Luke Skywalker succeeds in destroying
the Death Star, he gets a hero's welcome back
at the Rebel base.
Princess Leia is so relieved, she screams
out Luke's name, but it isn't "Leia" that
actor Mark Hamill calls out in response.
The actors have tried to cover up the gaff,
but it's hard to miss Hamill calling his co-star
Carrie Fisher by her first name.
Guardians of the Galaxy
With a cast as talented as Marvel's gang of
space outlaws, some improv is to be expected.
But actual accidents, like star Chris Pratt
dropping an all-powerful orb of universal
destruction are a different story.
Director James Gunn has confirmed that Chris
Pratt really did drop the orb by accident,
but stayed in character and finished the shot,
meaning it could be still be used in the finished
cut.
Proving once and for all that it's nearly
impossible to find where the actor's clumsy
personality ends, and Peter Quill begins.
Lemony Snicket’s A Series of Unfortunate
Events
The movie version of this novel series lived
up to its name, but even in this series of
unfortunate events, one happy accident made
it through editing, thanks to Jim Carrey's
famously quick thinking.
When the movie's child stars meet their villainous
uncle, he proves his career as an actor isn't
limited to the stage, asking them for a second
take.
But the line wasn't in the script - Carrey
actually wanted to try his line again, but
stayed in character when asking his costars.
Since the strange moment fit the movie's tone,
the director decided to leave it in.
North by Northwest
Considered to be one of Alfred Hitchcock's
best, and most parodied movies, there's one
part of North by Northwest that all involved
would rather forget.
When the Star Cary Grant winds up taking a
trip in the back of a police car, the actors
rely on old fashioned tricks to make the ride
seem more realistic to the audience.
When the driver takes a hard left, Grant slides
to the right like he's supposed to – while
the other policeman misses the cue completely,
meaning Grant needs to give him a push, and
leaving audiences to wonder how the obviously
blown take was the version Hitchcock left
in the final cut.
Cabin in the Woods
One of the biggest laughs of this horror comedy
comes when one torture technician gets to
see a kill from his favourite mobster up close.
Too close.
The scene was intended to be truly grotesque,
as the Merman prop was rigged to pump out
thick streams of blood as it consumed its
victim.
With the effect working perfectly, the crew
decided they might as well let the blood tank
empty out before stopping the camera.
But it was only when the tank started to run
dry that the flowing blood turned into erratic
spraying, and every crew member began uncontrollably
laughing.
The tone changed immediately, and the director
decided the joke was too good to leave out,
swapping gore for a gag, and proving that
behind-the-scenes luck can still result in
movie magic.
Serenity
The heroes of Joss Whedon's Firefly were up
against an entire planetary alliance in this
big screen finale to the TV show, taking a
suicide mission into enemy territory to get
a life or death message to the public.
But when the truth came out, even the crew's
main enemy decides they shouldn't be punished.
Unfortunately, the director had planned to
skip over the enemy soldiers standing down
entirely - which meant he never filmed the
scene.
Getting creative, Whedon used footage of the
end of the shot, when he shouted "cut!" and
the actors simply lowered their weapons.
It did the trick, but they weren't alone:
look closely, and you'll see the crew member
lowering their camera straight through the
frame.
The Wizard of Oz
The villain of this classic movie met her
end by melting in water, but the actress got
it much, much worse.
When the Wicked Witch of the West makes her
first exit from Munchkinland, she does so
in a puff of red smoke, and a burst of fire.
It's a memorable effect, but a pretty flawed
one: not only can the trapdoor letting out
smoke clearly be seen opening from the floor's
set, but it begins to pour out before the
Witch even hits her mark.
So why was it left in the movie?
In a later take, actress Margaret Hamilton
was severely burned when the fire erupted
early, taking her out of action for almost
two months.
When the actress returned, she refused any
more fire stunts, so the studio was forced
to use a rehearsal take in the final cut,
obvious errors, mistimed smoke and all.
Days of Thunder
Even actors can get starstruck when working
alongside mega stars like Tom Cruise, and
his game was proving a problem even early
in his career.
Playing the part of NASCAR driver Cole Trickle
in Days of Thunder, a head injury led to a
love affair with his characters doctor.
When the couple spent the weekend with Cole's
former rival Rowdy Burns, introductions are
made with Rowdy's wife Jenny.
But she doesn't need to be told who her husband's
famous friend is ("Hi Tom" "Hey Jenny").
Somehow, her flub - and Cruise ignoring her
mistake - wound up in the finished movie.
Spy Kids
It's still hard to believe that director Robert
Rodriguez is responsible for mature action
movies like Desperado AND the family friendly
movie series Spy Kids.
But it turns out that filming fewer action-packed
scenes isn't necessarily that much easier.
When Rodriguez was capturing an early shot
of actress Carla Gugino in front of a set
of mirrors, he made an unexpected cameo alongside
her reflection.
What should have led to a blown take and a
good laugh was left intact, with Rodriguez
apparently deciding his blunder was too funny
to edit out.
Terminator 2
Arnold Schwarzenegger may be more acclaimed
for his action skills than his comedy chops
these days, but in the role of The Terminator,
the actor could do no wrong.
He even tried a little improv.
When his battle with the more powerful T-1000
in the movie’s sequel left him severely
damaged and losing limbs, he still managed
to come to John Connor’s rescue.
In the script, the Terminator had no line
to speak after saving John, with James Cameron
simply saying that he emerges “looking like
he needs a vacation.”
After filming the scene several times, Arnold
decided to give the director a laugh, turning
his description into an actual line.
It got a laugh, but Cameron decided it actually
fit the character perfectly, and made sure
that was the take he went with.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite outtakes
or happy accidents in blockbuster movies?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to check out our friends at TheRichest
and subscribe to their channel!
They just released an awesome video about
movie mistakes we are sure you’re going
to love!
Thanks again for watching and make sure to
subscribe to our channel to watch more videos
like this one.